Yahoo investors have a lot to digest
when the company reports earnings after
the bell there are outstanding questions
surrounding its plans to sell its assets
to verizon due to multiple data breaches
and there's a report the company faces a
Securities and Exchange Commission
investigation do to those breaches
Bloomberg editor-at-large Corey Johnson
joins us now from San Francisco with
more and Corey let's start with this SEC
investigation what do we know about it
what is the Commission looking into we
might have expected this a couple years
ago as you see evidence requirements of
companies notify investors in their
10-qs in their 10 KS and perhaps even
with extraordinary 8 k's that there's
been a hack and then it could infect the
investor value it's something that's I
think important and a good thing the SEC
to do to let investors know that the
thing that they have an investment in
may have changed in value because of
this hack and Yahoo did not release this
kind of information so the question is
it's it's it's an old saw but it's worth
repeating what do they know and when did
they know it because if they did not
disclose these things to investors it
could be a violation of this rule that
they disclose these kinds of things so
the company we subject do any kinds of
fines or more but maybe the bigger
question looming is what is the ultimate
value of this business after these hacks
will there be any leniency from the SEC
at all Corey given its troubles recent
past and this desperation to sell I
think the greater concern might be what
happened the stock price and if in fact
the value of the company as determined
by the market declined after this and
one could certainly look at this and say
no harm no follow that foul because you
know with the SEC with the merger of
verizon looks like it continues the
stock price held up so if the in fact
the stock price didn't change much even
after the disclosures maybe the timing
of the disclosure wasn't as bad a fouls
it might have been in a different
circumstance to the socket perhaps
plummeted after the news Corey I know
that you've talked to tim armstrong ave
well about the deal what's happening
behind the scenes what's the forensic
investigation like what is verizon
looking at here is it weighs whether to
proceed with the deal on how to proceed
with the deal yeah I mean I think
fundamentally what this comes down to is
what kind of deal of Verizon think it
was getting and Tim Armstrong has been
very clear Tim Armstrong horse who runs
the AOL business a was acquired by
Verizon and he runs most of those media
businesses under verizon what kind of
deals do you think about what acid did
he
get from yahoo did the value of that
asset significantly change based on the
hack and in fact did the did do they
still want to go ahead with a steal and
everything that he has said suggests
that while they're going to do their
responsible thing and look at the
business at verizon and look at look at
the busy yahoo and see if that has has
changed to try to get the best deal for
verizon and its shareholders he seems to
indicate that he thinks he got a steal
at the price of acquiring the yahoo
assets and that this accumulation of a
billion users there are very few things
in the internet like this and then
horizons glad to have this under their
tent and of course we get earnings after
the bell corey and i think they won't
matter a lot i mean maybe we'll see if
there's a material change in terms of
number of users or or advertisers
willingness to go to the platform but
the earnings are so under the radar that
the company is not even going to have a
conference call because they expect to
go through this verizon acquisition and
complete the deal so they think that the
outside shareholders who are not verizon
don't really matter at this point and
therefore they're not even going to
communicate with shareholders more than
the press release as required by the sec